- How to turn 100 bucks into 1000?
I'll tell you how to turn zero into 1000.
Go to Craigslist, where's
my Craigslist video?
Turn off the music Avi.
Honestly I think I just
eliminated for the first time--
(beeping)
I think I just eliminated
for the first time
in my career the excuse of no money.
We think a lot about
money and opportunity.
Let me tell you about an opportunity
that I can't get out of my head.
This is like a big day for me.
Literally for 30 years, I've had to like
pay under to that excuse.
It's over.
There's a website called craigslist.com,
under the sales section,
there's a free section underneath that.
Where people list shit
that they wanna get rid of.
Go take it, for free 'cause most people
just want you to pick it up
'cause it's bigger or what have you.
If you happen to actually
have like a truck
or like a bigger vehicle,
then you are really set.
Carry this shit on the bus.
If you're broke, grab this, go on the bus,
sit on the bus like this,
everybody's gonna look at you,
be like yeah, yeah, yeah, keep laughin',
come home, take a picture.
And then you list it on
Facebook Marketplace,
the arbitrage of the internet.
We see this in retail
where people buy things
and trying to post on Amazon.
15 bucks, somebody's like
yeah I'll take your table.
Ding dong.
Yo hello, here you go.
And you sell it.
And when I think about this, I can't,
I've been dreaming about this
for the last 72 hours by the way.
The much more humble version
when you've got nothing,
if you're just sitting
like, I need money like,
all those people that were like,
yo can somebody buy me Gary
Vee's book I can't afford it?
That means, you know, $17.
I think it's like $300 a week.
If you take your 6:00 P.M. to 9:00 P.M.
Monday and Tuesday picking up shit
and then reposting it
on Facebook Marketplace
and then meeting people on Saturday
to come to your home and grab it.
And then somebody's gonna say but damn,
it's gonna take 40 minutes to go there,
40 minutes to take on the
bus, five minutes to post,
seven minutes, I'm like
but what are you doing
with your time anyway?
You're laying on the phone
going on people's accounts
who are fuckin' winning
saying this guy's bullshit.
'Cause that's what you're
doing with your time
when you're losing.
It's crazy to me that the
only thing that stops somebody
from winning is education
and the work ethic, right?
I understand that.
But education comes in
so many different forms.
Go to Craigslist, get free
shit from the free section,
take it and then put it on
Facebook Marketplace and sell it.
Zero to 1000 Steve, zero to 1000.